this guy is just he's just like sort of
just like a terrible Lefty propagandist
again from Al Jazeera so you can sort of
put that together uh anyway here he is
Matt taibi on his show related to Elon
Musk and the Twitter files and just
watch this
would you criticize him today for
batting journalists for working with
Modi government to shut down speech for
you know being anti-union you can go for
I'll give you as much time as you like
would you like to criticize much now no
I don't I don't particularly want to
um look I didn't I didn't criticize him
really before
uh and I think that what the Twitter
files are is a step in the right
direction
um but it's the same Twitter that he's
running right now
well I'll ask you a specific one
no no no no no that's bad faith Matt
sorry you say that Twitter hold on hold
on let me finish my question you're
saying that he's good for Twitter and
good for speech I'm saying he's using
Twitter to help one of the most
right-wing governments in the world
sense of speech I will criticize that
will you
I have to do I have to look at the story
first I'm not looking at it now hold on
hold on I I posted the story two weeks
ago you tweeted on me I don't watch the
midi Hassan show
I don't watch the many Assad show I mean
it's just perfect nobody does like trust
me we have way more viewers on a daily
basis with than this guy it doesn't even
matter but anyway the point of this is
when I talk about how they launder the
lies right so the media completely
buried the hunter Biden story for all
the time that a whole bunch of us were
saying they were Shadow Banning you know
if you'd say this about the lab leak or
this about the vaccines or mandates
we're getting suspended and banned the
media didn't care about that then taibi
releases he's one of the people that
releases these Twitter files Hassan has
no interest in that he has no interest
in the fact that the government has been
exposed to be colluding to silence Free
Speech a direct violation of the first
movement he's not interested in that
he's just trying to get Matt taibi on
whether Matt tybe is upset that Elon
Musk doesn't like unions like it's it's
just completely irrelevant Elon Musk is
allowed to have his own feelings on uh
unions he's also allowed to have his own
feelings on literally anything because
he's a free citizen of the free at least
for now United States of America anyway
here's just a tiny bit more and this is
like a full wrecking of this Hassan
fella and I don't think we're going to
need to talk about this guy anymore
after today so we'll go back to our
regularly scheduled
Joy Reed Joe Scarborough nonsense here
you go
outline and muscles
the hilarity of this coming from MSNBC
which did nothing but vomit up uh fake
Russian good stories that came straight
from the FBI for six consecutive years
you guys still haven't apologized for
all right
in that period so I've got nothing to
apologize I'm asking you you're
[Music]
thank you for appearing on the show
appreciate it I don't think I've ever
read about the hunter Biden story so
maybe you should apologize to me
including for putting words in my mouth
you said at the beginning I put words I
never said a word about the underbody
[Music]
do you see why they want to censor
people
[Music]